[Music]
[Music]
so
it's seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast these are our top stories this
morning
football's coming rome excitement builds
as england prepare for their euros
quarter final match with ukraine
in italy tonight i will definitely be
screaming i'm gonna i think
i'm really gonna be shouting
i mean like we're gonna make it up for
the fans at home
the yorkshire pillow sky news meets
those instrumental in the upbringing of
one of england's stars of the tournament
so far
calvin phillips he's one of the best
players i've seen
you know uh in this era you know who can
play that position
in a way that it does for club and
country
also this morning carry on the cover-up
leading doctors say measures like
mask wearing should remain after the
19th of july to limit the spread of
covid
more than 700 sudden and unexpected
deaths are reported in canada as the
country continues to swelter in a
record-breaking heatwave
plus in the spotlight english landmarks
are to be bathed in blue to mark the
73rd anniversary of the nhs
and to thank staff for their pandemic
efforts
good morning heavy and possibly thundery
downpours
could pop up just about anywhere across
the uk and ireland over the weekend
it will be rather warm and humid as well
i'll bring you all the details later on
and a quarter two we'll have a look at
the papers with journalists alfie adam
and thomas copeland
[Music]
good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast thank you for joining us
england will try to qualify for their
first european championship
semi-final for 25 years when they face
ukraine
this evening in rome after ending a
55-year wait to beat
germany in a knockout tie earlier this
week gareth southgate's england side
go to the italian capital full of
confidence but after playing their first
four games at wembley today's match is
england's first away fixture
with covert travel restrictions meaning
fans in the uk
have been told not to travel to the game
our europe correspondent michelle
clifford reports now from rome
the england players spent a quiet night
in rome resting up in their hotel ahead
of a match
which could take them a step closer to
becoming european champions
but when they emerge to take on ukraine
today there will be no stadium rammed
with fans to cheer them on
coveted restrictions have prevented
thousands traveling from the uk
to italy but some avid supporters have
secured tickets and seats
and were able to make the journey from
their homes in the european union
the bennett family flew in from cyprus
thrilled at being able to attend this
england
game especially because the semi-finals
and final
will be held in the uk i will definitely
be screaming i'm gonna i think
i'm really gonna be shouting she can
share i mean like
we're gonna make it up for the fans at
home who can't come because i think
obviously there's not gonna be as many
of us so for the the few that are there
we really need to make an impact the
next uh
two semis and final is at wembley so
at least they've got something to see
and i'm certain england will be there
in rome's fan zone where italian
supporters celebrated their team's
victory over belgium
the number of spectators will be limited
for the england game
so too in the stadium while there'll be
checks on where people have traveled
from
england fans buoyed by the team's defeat
of germany this week might have been
tempted to hop foot it to rome
but the warning from the authorities has
been don't do it
there wouldn't have been time to
complete the mandatory five-day
quarantine
before the quarter-final with ukraine
and the regional health chief had strong
words for anyone
attempting to break the rules
i want to tell the english fans that you
must not die for a match
i would invite them to cheer for their
team england from home
because coming here would be risky and
also
it would be impossible to enter the
stadium whilst england players admitted
they would miss the throng of the crowd
in the stadium
manager gareth southgate said the team
might actually benefit from the match
being played in italy i think it's good
to come away from
wembley now it would have been hard to
replicate the atmosphere we had the
other day
three days later and i think to have a
different focus different surroundings
different sort of a challenge is good
for us tens of thousands will be out to
support the team
but we'll be watching from home
territory just hoping
tonight's match will lead england to
playing their next at
wembley very soon michelle clifford sky
news
rome leading doctors are urging the
government to keep
some measures in place after the full
lifting of lockdown restrictions
later this month amid what they describe
as an alarming rise in covert cases the
british medical association says
sensible cautious measures will be key
to preventing
further lockdowns let's speak to our
correspondent charlotte lomas who's in
the newsroom for us this morning morning
charlotte what do they want us to keep
in place
well kimberly it's not time to throw
away your face mask
just yet as the british medical
association said
it would make no sense to get rid of all
of those
safety measures in their entirety and
actually when it comes to easing
restrictions
it shouldn't be an all or nothing
decision and instead
they are calling for face masks to
continue to be worn in public enclosed
spaces such as in shops
or on public transport they're also
calling for the message to remain
strong that social distancing is the
best way to reduce the risk
of infection and reduce the risk of
getting ill
from covid and of course this comes as
covert cases are continuing to rise
at an alarming rate the latest figures
from public health
england show an increase of 46 percent
on last week and while um hospital
admissions
have remained low they are also a rising
now
at a pace and there are twice as many
coveted patients
in hospital or on ventilators as this
time
last month so the leading doctors the
british medical association
are saying why throw away all the
progress that this country has made over
the last 18 months
and it would be sensible to keep some of
those safety measures to make sure that
covert cases are kept under control
and that we prevent a future lockdown or
future spike in cases
charlotte thank you well it comes as the
comedian david walliams and harry potter
star jim broadbent are among a number of
familiar faces appearing in a new covert
19
vaccine promotion get that vaccine
i've had
[Music]
the musical inspired video released
ahead of the nhs 73rd birthday
on monday aims to encourage all over 18s
to take up the jab
right well let's have a look at the
latest covert data for the uk there have
been
27 125 new
cases 27 more deaths have been reported
that means the total number of people
who've died within 20 28 days of a
positive test
that now stands at 128
188 the latest vaccination figures show
another 152
525 people have got their first jab
and 193 066
have got their second in total over 45
million people have had one dose
33.22 million are now fully vaccinated
let's take a look at some of the other
stories making the news this morning and
officials in north miami beach have
evacuated a residential tower block just
five miles from the site of the surf
side building collapse
in which at least 22 people lost their
lives it comes as officials investigate
high-rise buildings across florida to
make sure some
substantial structural problems aren't
being ignored
hundreds of people are thought to have
been killed by a record-breaking heat
wave that's sweeping across parts of the
u.s and western canada
719 sudden and unexpected deaths have
been reported in british columbia
over the past week while nearly a
hundred deaths in
oregon are being investigated as heat
related
meanwhile barbados has been battered by
its first hurricane for over 60
years the island is one of the few
holiday destinations on the uk's green
travelist and it was first hit
it was the first to be hit by what is
called hurricane elsa
residents in miami are now being told to
prepare themselves as the storm
heads for u.s shores
a white police chief in ohio has
resigned after he was caught on cctv
placing an offensive note on the desk of
a black officer
the police union representing the black
officer filed a harassment complaint
against anthony campo
after footage showed him placing the
note saying ku
klux klan and a jacket displayed in the
kkk style on the desk
mr campos said the incident was intended
as a quote
prank
landmarks across england will light up
blue today to mark 73
the 73rd anniversary of the nhs and to
thank style for their contribution
during the coronavirus pandemic wembley
arch
salisbury cathedral and the liver
building are among more than 70 sites
taking part
and let's have a look at this morning's
front pages now
the daily mail leads with business
bosses mps and health experts demanding
boris johnson reform covert rules on
self-isolation before they quote
[ __ ] the economy the telegraph
says downing street is refusing to be
drawn on whether social distancing rules
had been broken following michael gove's
announcement that his marriage
is over the eye goes with hopes of
quarantine free foreign trips to europe
for those who've had both doses of a
coronavirus vaccine
the express leads with the german
chancellor angela merkel backing down on
her plans to make british tourists
entering the eu self-isolate
that's after a meeting with boris
johnson
the time says fully vaccinated people
who've been in contact with someone with
covid
will be able to carry on life as normal
in a few weeks without the need to take
daily tests
the guardian goes with labour's win in
the batley and spam by-election the
party's leader shakir stammer saying kim
ledbeter won it with her campaign based
on unity and
decency the ft
says london's share of the european
market has steadily risen in recent
months
making it europe's largest share trading
center
england's euro 2020 clash with ukraine
makes the front of the mirror with
captain harry kane promising to pull out
all the stops to win the match saying
we will give it everything
and in the sun pool gascoigne says
england can win the euros if fans throw
all their support behind manager gareth
southgate
let's stay with that story um right now
because england
will try to qualify for their first
european championship semi-final for 25
years when they face ukraine
this evening in rome today's match is
england's first away fixture of the
tournament
with those curved travel restrictions
meaning that fans in the uk
have been told not to travel to the game
but perhaps brits living in other parts
of the eu can help bolster support i'm
joined now
by eleanor and neil winrow um they're
flying in from sicily
you're driving at the moment where are
you going
actually we've parked up we're on our
way to palermo airport we live in masala
which is about an hour's drive away
and then we fly in from palermo to rome
so we'll be in rome about midday
and the excitement levels where are they
oh it's it's incredible
uh i i watched the match on tuesday
night obviously and never thought about
going to the match
until i read the news on wednesday
morning and thought
i've got a chance to go and see england
play
it was quite difficult getting my hands
on tickets but
fortunately my oldest son he put out the
jungle drums and actually found someone
that knows someone that knows some
and so i actually got a ticket from
someone in switzerland
that's fantastic um are you gonna make
up for all the fans who can't make it
there
i hope so we'll try to make as much
noise as possible it's
it's a great honor to actually go and
see england play and this is the first
time for me
uh in in my years i've been a football
fan
it was quite a match to see isn't it
what does eleonora think
yeah well obviously my wife's italian so
we had a good match last night as well
so fingers crossed
we'll be able to have a an italian
english final
so we'll be uh quite partisan in our
house cross that's going to be
that's going to be high stakes indeed
you're going to be traveling
on your own no to that match probably
well obviously yeah
trying to get tickets for wembley is
impossible so
it's just fantastic that we've both had
the chance to go to rome today to see uh
the lads play and hopefully pull off of
a great win
yeah um so you guys live in sicily is
that correct
yes yes we live in masala yes okay and
are there lots of brits there
very few in fact uh not many at all uh
in fact i only know of one of the brits
that lives
in masala and his name's neil as well
that's ridiculous is the other nil going
to the match
uh i haven't been in touch with him for
a while so
i i doubt it i won't don't suppose
you'll manage to get any tickets
it's going to be difficult isn't it
talking about fan numbers again
because the atmosphere at wembley was
just
so fantastic the last match i mean what
do you think it's going to be this time
around
well i think it's going to be very
difficult to replicate
i mean i just seen the the crowds
in other particular stadiums where fans
are traveling away from home
it's it's very difficult to fill this
the stadiums
uh but we'll try to make as much noise
as possible to make up for the lack of
numbers
they'll be counting on you um okay a can
they do it
b what's your goal prediction okay
well yes there's no reason why we
shouldn't be able to beat
ukraine you know so it's
less nervous i'd like to see england get
a goal or two in the first half for a
change
just to put us at ease a little bit
because it's always nerve-wracking
watching england
so it would be nice it is it is eleonora
hey my wife doesn't speak very much
ah okay okay well listen we can we love
your support eleanor
thanks a lot thank you so much for
chatting to us
drive safely have a fantastic flight
thank you our italian director
thank you bye bye thank you so much
i look so sunny there doesn't it not so
much here
let's find out what the weather's doing
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning there will be some warm
sunny spells this weekend but there'll
be plenty of showers and the showers
could strike pretty
much anywhere and it's rather gray this
morning across much of england wales
ireland and northern ireland we've got
outbreaks of showery rain moving
northwards a brighter start for parts of
scotland although a few showers possible
here as
well and it will feel quite humid and
muggy today
now the showers could turn quite heavy
slow moving and thundery
mainly across central and eastern parts
of england later on we could also see
those some pretty nasty downpours
across parts of the southwest and some
quite heavy ones too for parts of
ireland so some fundraising showers
possible
and of course that doesn't mean we have
a risk of localized flooding
temperatures in the sunnier spells and
actually the very far southeast might
escape some of the showers
we're looking at temperatures into the
low 20s now the rain moving northwards
into parts of scotland overnight
we'll have more showers to come as we
head through the day tomorrow
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
southeast asia correspondent in bangkok
[Music]
[Music]
our job is to tell the truth this is a
forgotten front line
they are dying here
[Music]
boys we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us
get ready instructing you to stay at
home
i don't believe we did that it's pretty
special isn't it
[Applause]
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
mandatory evacuation i'm greg milam
sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles it is almost
impossible to predict
where these fires will go next
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend
and twist metal are you trying to run me
over to phillip no go away look like it
sir
you need to leave but you're not
understanding
i've seen the dark side of america
[Music]
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart
of america's opioid crisis i've seen
heartbreaking
human stories christ
church has been changed forever by what
happened here
hello my name is nadja frontier
my name is ryan matthews i'm the marine
assistant
at rather a research station which is to
the west of the west antarctic peninsula
[Music]
so far i've been here for five months
and it is an absolutely wonderful
experience
my name is fatima zanzilla the founder
of ikisa from kuwait where we face many
environmental
problems related to waste pollution the
frustration
and lack of information we are
collecting recyclables
from houses schools and businesses in
order to recycle them
in exchange of your recyclable to get a
tree
[Music]
good morning there is only one story in
town this morning yes
you've guessed it england playing
tonight
this sports bulletin is brought to you
by vitality
committed to getting 100 million people
20 more active by 2025
the other word that i always remember
you referring to in team talks was risk
you're doing one nothing with 15 minutes
ago
what's the point in certainly your back
forward
your regular midfield and two strikers
what's the point there
the risk is shove people in the box
because the other team react to that
you shove three and four in the box get
the ball in there
it's that's the risk because you can
lose the breakaway
the counter attack quite easily and we
watch games that way
you were offended by it felt me like
you're offended by the club being beaten
by liverpool or city at any level
and it made you angry and the build-up
to those games
your face was most a little bit like it
is now was it a dislike of you was it
the rivalry what was it that made you
feel that way because it was just
different in the club it's my respect to
liverpool
when i was a manager mum i went down to
liverpool
straining for a week and i saw the
intensity of their training and
and the consistency they had
so when i came to united and they were
running all the titles i made that point
and it's like one is aberdeen there's
only two clubs you need to be
in scotland to win everything that's
reason celtic
at that time when i came to united
there's only one club to beat to win the
white a week
and that's liverpool so that was my
intention
that was up ever then to produce a team
we could beat them
not necessarily beating them every game
but windy throughout the weeks
and i knew that if you beat liverpool
you're on the right path i only
recognized this properly when i became
captain for that last four or five years
that you used to stand
outside the dressing room door and the
captain couldn't go out past you until
you were there
every single match you make sure you why
did
it's this influence over referees this
looking down the corridor it's the
looking at the away team what was the
reason you stood outside that door
so that everybody could see it was it
for your own team or was it for the
others down the court oh for their own
team
okay but there was one occasion i don't
know if you remember this
but we were doing three nothing to
tottenham autonom
and i never said i was in the dressing
room do you remember that yeah i sat in
the radio
and it was buddy burning hot too and it
says
i do remember actually no next goal is
the winner as i said
and i went to the door and teddy sharing
would played with us of course
was their captain and they came out to
the door and what looked to me
and turned and said to his players don't
let them score early
let's go in the first minute remember
that yeah
i thought i thought that killed him i'm
with teddy i'm going to say that to them
because i looked at them you know and
they look to me
and uh i just come on we can win this
it's a funny game
at the age of six i had meningitis
septicemia
and they said i'd never walk again my
achilles in my left leg shrunk so that
meant that
sort of my knees weren't in line with my
hips so they said that i'd constantly
have problems with that a year and a
half later
i started going outside i was back
walking running
and then i got signed for qpr age eight
so
yeah it was a miracle really that i was
being able to walk and run again
how did you go from you know struggling
to walk to
be able to run around and be able to
play with the kids but the kids were
really good at football
both my legs were in plaster for about
six months
and i was in a wheelchair i can't
remember exactly how i started walking
again
but i used to have to wear like night
splints so my legs were constantly
[Music]
in splints to to help me walk mentally
when i um come out of hospital i was a
vet like a different child my mom said
it wasn't the same
child that went into hospital and i had
brain damage from it
and i was on life support for six days
i've got obviously adhd i was diagnosed
ocd and personality disorder i've got a
few things
um so that as well as sort of playing
football
was a massive sort of risk i was lonely
i felt
like a very lonely place with this
injury now
and beforehand i was constantly
i was constantly on a high i always
thought i would get through whatever i
go through and that's that
committed to getting 100 million people
20 more active by 2025
coming up on sky news breakfast we'll
have a special report from the front
line of the u.s mexico border crisis
[Music]
so
[Music]
well the england squad have arrived in
rome ahead of their quarterfinal matchup
with ukraine
and their sites are firmly fixed on
making the final four in the tournament
euro 2020 has showcased some of the
greatest footballing talents in the
world but
one young yorkshire man has also left
quite the impression
tom parmenter has been in leeds to find
out more about one of england's
players of the tournament so far
back in the winter a mural popped up in
the middle of leeds
it saluted calvin phillips a son of this
city
who they knew was a bit special
now phillips has played every minute of
england's tournament
so far and has proved that he is the
business
calvin grew up over there he just over
that side of the
housing estate there high school's over
that way yes that's where he went to
farley academy
and then his mum's where mum lives over
there so it's
quite a good circle really close circle
which is like say
he still is around here so he's still in
his area which is brilliant for us
paul and ian used to drop him off back
home after training at wurtley football
club
in the west of leeds to see their calvin
now running england's midfield is a bit
special
even when it was cold or it was snowing
it'd just come off and smile
even if we lost drawn i'll win he just
smiled all the time
and they were a pleasure to coach really
well in the game against um
croatia was it when he knocked the ball
through for for sterling to score
we've seen him do that loads of times
it's the same little run
the same run as if you're not having
this ball off me
and then he pushes it through gap then
we've seen him do it here and we've done
it before for us
the man on calvin phillips's shoulder in
the mural is south african defender
lucas radiby he was known as the chief
in the famous leeds united side
of the 90s he's one of the best players
i've seen
you know in this era you know who can
play that position
in a way that he does for club and
country a great platform
you know to showcase and represent you
know
a holistic picture of what it means to
be a food a professional footballer
you know from the streets of in the
community
you know to the helm you know of the
best in
playing against the best in the world he
has been nicknamed the yorkshire pierlo
after the italian great andrea pilo
but calvin phillips is now his own man
on loan to england but at home
just here tom parmenter sky news
leads
a humanitarian crisis is rearing its
head once again in the us as migration
across the mexican border reaches its
highest level
for two decades now along the border
those migrating from mexico to the u.s
have
many points to cross since january when
president joe biden came into office
it's estimated
over 50 000 unaccompanied children have
made the journey
in may u.s customs and border protection
said it detained
more than 180 000 people that's in may
alone now the rio grande spanning across
the state of texas
is a popular crossing point due to its
variation in levels
between 10 in the morning and two in the
afternoon the river flow drops
significantly
allowing the dangerous journey to be
much less treacherous
the cities of acuna and piedras negras
are
some of the most popular places for that
final push to u.s soil
from there our chief correspondent
stuart ramsey sent this report
carrying pretty much everything he owns
he stops at an
island in the middle of the rio grande
the border between mexico
and the united states
he turns back to his wife and baby
nervously negotiating the rocky riverbed
swinging his child onto his shoulders
and holding his wife's hand
they make their way
they're from haiti it's probably taken
weeks or months to get here
now finally they're steps away from
america
they know they'll be detained and
they'll claim asylum
but these final steps could be the start
of a new life
to them any legal issues are worth the
risk
in just a couple of days we've watched
dozens cross like this
they wait for the river flow to drop and
in broad daylight they cross
mainly their families
the united states border patrols on and
off the river are constant
armed officers riding air boats scan the
banks looking for migrants attempting to
cross
but in the days we've been here we
didn't see them intercept anyone
mainly we watched as they searched with
helicopter support hovering overhead
in truth they just can't stop the
crossings happening
we came across two families on the
riverbank preparing to cross
haitians once again they've been in
mexico for three months
but have decided to make their move
their story
is always the same haiti is impossible
to live in
uh and what are you hoping
will happen when you get to america
[Music]
objectifying
be
this group and unaccompanied minors from
anywhere are pretty much guaranteed to
enter the migration processing system
others are usually just kicked back but
that said
tens of thousands just like these people
are trying to get in
every single month but it's easy to see
where the migrants gather before they
cross the united states everywhere's
full of rubbish there's also paperwork
on what to do when you get to america
interestingly there's also abandoned id
cards that are here
worth remembering too that it's not just
men going across its families as well
we have a pile of unused nappies here
and a colouring book for children and
that's really important because
since january this year 50 000
unaccompanied minors
have attempted to make this really quite
dangerous crossing
fernando hernandez is from honduras he
is just 16 years old
he's traveled 2 000 miles by bus to get
here
he's doing this he says for his family
and why did you leave
he left us to attempt the crossing but
turned back
he can't swim 2 000 miles
but 50 meters short for now
the draw of the united states and the
lengths people are prepared to go to to
get here both legal and illegal is
staggering
they're breaking records right now but
in reality
no administration has ever found a way
to stop it
and possibly never will stuart ramsey
sky news
on the rio grande in mexico
good news ahead for uk holiday makers
this summer as a large cruise liner is
coming back for the first time in six
years royal caribbean's anthem of the
seas is returning to southampton to take
guests on a cruise around the british
isles but
what will post-pandemic cruising
actually look like
caribbean's vice president ben bolden
joins us now good morning ben thanks a
lot for joining us
what has demand been like for this
cruise
good morning i'm delighted to say that
demand's been fantastic
raw caribbean groups started sailing in
november
in markets like singapore and we've had
an unprecedented number of guests there
standing with us
and we've seen that trent that demand
translate across to the uk market
so we're really excited ahead of this
summer's domestic programme
yeah i'm sure a lot of people are
excited um about this ben but at the
beginning of the pandemic
cruise ships and the disaster stories
the horror stories that we were hearing
coming out of there
how exactly are you going to make your
cruise ships
covered safe
well we've been out of service ever
since we voluntarily suspended
operations in march
of last year so we've been out of
service for 15 months now
and we've pulled together a panel of
leading
epidemiologists and experts around the
world to spend real time focused on our
protocols for when we return
and we're ready to return we've got a
very very coherent multi-layered
approach to the protocols that we're
applying
and that starts with testing rigorously
before cruising a requirement for our
guests to be vaccinated over the age of
18
and multiple other protocols across the
course of the sailing
including starting our programs with a
reduced capacity to enable social
distancing
and of course we will be mask wearing
initially as per
life here today what happens if people
test positive when they're on that
cruise i'm assuming that there's going
to be testing throughout
the actual cruise
well we test uh before people cruise
the cruises are relatively short so we
won't be testing throughout the cruise
but we test everybody who's vaccinated
and we also test everybody i.e children
under the age of 18
at the terminal before they before they
board the ship
then so we're very very good sorry to
jump in there ben are they going to be
jumping on and off
no our first cruises are not going our
crews are just going out to sea
we will as we move forward into the next
few weeks start to visit and multiple
multiple uh locations around the uk
but this is a domestic programme
initially and of course when people do
go out we'll be going in a curated shore
excursion so we'll be great so they are
going on to the shore
sorry ben so they are actually going
onto the shore
yes they will be yes so are you going to
test them when they come back
no because it they're they're
essentially take an example one of our
cruisers will be going to liverpool
when we go to liverpool we won't be
testing people as they get off the ship
or as they get back on the ship because
they're not leaving the uk
we're testing them when they arrive with
us and we believe that's uh proficient
for the situation here as things evolve
when we start to go internationally it's
very different
yeah you know from the moment you take
are you requiring
pcr tests on the right on um when they
get on board they have to take a pcr
test
yeah so every one of our vaccinated
adult guests will have had a pcr test
within 72 hours of boarding the ship
so then the problem is is that if you
take that pcr test and you catch covid
between the test and the time you get on
the ship and then you get on the ship
and you're asymptomatic you know the
diamond princess they
they think that up to 75
of the passengers were asymptomatic if
you're not testing
while people are on board you could have
a huge breakout couldn't you
especially if you have a super spreader
on bra on board
well i think the the the situation very
much depends on the length of the
sailing
uh and where you're going where you're
sailing from so on longer sailings which
we aren't
doing at the moment from southampton but
we will be doing elsewhere in the world
we do have
testing during the cruise and also we
have testing
before people debark the cruise because
that facilitates them then being able to
fly home safely
so it very much depends on where we're
cruising for the uk
market we are taking solely uk
passengers
who we have tested before cruising
they're not leaving the uk
and hence the protocols are slightly
adjusted and they are in align with
public health england's requirements
okay ben thank you so much for talking
to us
thank you for having me all right time
now for a look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning heavy and thundery showers
are possible just about everywhere
this weekend but showers are very hit
and miss so some places may
prove luckier than others it's a rather
gray start across much of england wales
parts of ireland as well with
overnight showers still continuing
they'll push northwards through the day
with some rumbles of thunder as well not
looking too bad a start for parts of
scotland but here we'll see
the showers moving in later on now i
mentioned some of them could be heavy
and
thundery especially across central and
eastern parts of england also down
towards the south west so potentially
some localized flooding
it is rather warm and humid temperatures
into the low 20s and there will be some
sunny spells
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
7 43 now coming up on sky news breakfast
we're going to be looking at the papers
with the journalists afia adam and
thomas copeland see you then
at the start of this we reckon that you
needed somewhere around 65
70 percent of the population the whole
population to be
immune in order to have that herd
immunity which prevents the virus
spreading
now since then we've got these rather
more transmissible variants
particularly the delta so maybe that
figure's
gone up to around 70 percent because it
has a a
bigger r zero number
um and you know therefore we have to
think about vaccinating the
kids um because eighty percent of the
adult population if that only represents
fifty percent of the whole population
we're still too low to prevent the virus
spreading and it will spread in kids so
i i'm in favor if we can and when we can
of vaccinating children as well so that
the whole population
is immune to the point where the virus
can no longer circulate
kovid will be with us for quite a long
time we've got to get used to it we do
have outbreaks of course of other
virus infections in the winter
flu notably but also what we call
rhinoviruses common cold respiratory
syncytial virus
they come round every winter and perhaps
perhaps
uh kovid will be the same it's worth
observing however that the serious
pandemics
of the 20th century 1918 57 68 etc
uh which were in fact all flew in the
first
wave the first year those viruses those
pandemics were quite severe with a lot
of deaths as they went
on although those same viruses with
changes continued to circulate
they became attenuated they were less uh
virulent in the population
and caused less deaths and it may be
that when we're vaccinated and we've
seen
covid before if we do get infected in
the future
it may well be that it's significantly
more mild
than it has been on this first wave of
infections in the human population
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
you either live and recover or you die
so
[Music]
done
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
it's a rather mild start this morning
and a fairly gray one with some
outbreaks of rain
some heavy showers and thunderstorms
moving northwards across the country
today
could be a risk of localized flooding
for parts of central eastern england
and also the southwest of england some
heavy showers to watch out for
now rain and showers will reduce the
risk of pollen too low at times but we
are in peak grass pollen season at the
moment
and for many levels are looking high to
very high across the country
during any warm sunny spells
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
time for another look at the papers and
with us again our journalists afia adam
and thomas copeland hello again to you
both
thanks a lot for being here this morning
let's kick off with
the i and you appear michael gove and
his wife
are separating what are they saying
uh yes they are that's not the story i
was going to talk about but
why not if you tell us what you're going
to talk about
i'm sorry yes i was going to talk about
the school closures causing children
considerable harm so this was actually a
study that's been done by university
college london
and it says that up to 60 percent of
boys and 47 percent of girls
are experiencing anxiety now this study
was done
in february during the third lockdown
and it really gives us an
insight into the effects that the
lockdown has had on our children
not just on their education but on their
physical and mental
well-being as well um it discovered that
children who were out of the classroom
uh suffered considerable impact and we
know that there was a huge percentage of
children out of the classroom
lots of children did end up going to
school because they were
children of key workers so they were in
school but kids have been
up to excuse me who have been outside of
school
at risk from depression and anxiety
and it found that 53 percent of girls
and 44 of boys aged 13 to 18
had the symptoms of anxiety now when
we're talking about um
recovering our children from what has
been an
extremely tough time for them i have a
nine-year-old daughter so i've seen
firsthand how difficult she's found it
being out of school
and when we talk about getting our
children back into school there's been
lots of talk about
perhaps extending the school day so they
can catch up
on things like math and english and we
know that children up and down the
country
aren't deemed to be falling behind but i
think what this study shows
is actually how important it is for us
to be working on our children's
physical and mental health if you've got
such high numbers
of 13 to 18 year olds you know boys and
girls experiencing anxiety i think
that's something
that we really have to focus on as well
as well as catching them up in other
areas
yeah yeah i feel so true um let's go to
the front of the guardian now thomas
what has sakir stama been saying
well if you buy the guardian i'm sure
you'll find out he's writing for the
guardian today
on thursday's narrow by-election victory
in battle and spain
he's healing it as a victory as a
turning point for library talks there
are a lot about the decency that's the
headline
of his candidates uh kim led better
sister of joe cox who had the fights
a tough and at times fairly nasty
campaign
and with a lot of media attention as is
usually the case for by-elections now in
the end
it's kind of hard to say what this
really means for labour um you know this
was a very narrow victory 323
votes uh in a seat that labor have
have had since since the early 80s i
think 1983
and they normally win with you know what
a 5 000 6 000 average
majority so you know these overall
trends are still in place the toys are
gaining ground
in in areas like batley and spain are
finding it more difficult to cling on
um so you know labour still has to
grapple with these kind of existential
challenges there are two positives
though i think that
that kierstarmer could take away the
first is that
um 323 votes isn't a lot it's probably
likely that that is the kind of the
hancock effect
so a number of people i mean 323 but
that's a you know a block a couple of
streets just people who are put off
by the matt hancock story what they seem
to perhaps see was a sense of hypocrisy
a sense of entitlement is there a
narrative in there the kind of
born to rule one rule for them sense
that that cure stormer could cling on to
and start to build perhaps
the other thing is that you know
politics is about perspectives we all
know
this uh it was a narrow election victory
but it was a victory nonetheless
and changing this sense of labor decline
and trying to inject a sense of optimism
a sense of momentum that could be key
for kyrst armor it could be the first of
a very long journey undoubtedly
but trying to build from here is going
to be something that he's going to be
very keen to do
you know the final thing i suppose is
what's clear is kirsten will
will have slept easy in bed knowing that
if he'd lost
this uh campaign in battle and spain
it's probably al almost certain that he
would have been challenged for the
leadership there have been
stories of mining of don butler andrew
rayner even andy burnham um
raising a few uh eyebrows with some of
his comments recently but
you know he kept the seats very narrow
so he's safe in the leadership for noye
but a long long way to go a breather for
labor and we're actually going to be
talking to the shadow home secretary um
nick thomas simmons
in the next hour um let's go to the sun
affair
gaza backs gaffer yes so paul gascoigne
has been talking to the sun
ahead of the huge england match tonight
in rome against ukraine
and he is saying that look gareth gate
can
take england all the way he's saying
he's the answer to everything for us
and we need to believe in him so we know
that gaza
and and gareth southgate have played
together four years
and they're in the 1996 tournament
together where england actually went out
to germany um yes so gaza is telling us
that to trust in gareth spice gate
and you know i think gareth southgate
really has come through as the manager
that england have needed
for a long time you know and he's
expressed his views to the fans
on taking the knee on so many other
things it was a really interesting essay
that he actually penned
on about britishness about the team and
i think that's really good that he's
done that
to reach out to the fans we hope that
that can translate
to the team we hope that they're not
going to miss you know the 12th man the
roar of the fans when they do play
in that stadium in rome and we hope that
they can go
all the way you know i'm scottish you
can tell by my accent so scotland was
actually my team
unfortunately you know we didn't do so
well so i'm rooting for england now
oh well that's good we're all english
today
um right uh thomas are you going to be
watching the match
well i'm an unfortunate combination of
not english and don't care about
football
so i'm not sure if that's a criminal
offense tonight but
i'm afraid i i won't really i mean i i
suppose i hope england do well
in the broader sense but i i i i can
tell you that i'll be i'll be sleeping
in my bed just fine no matter what
happens
i'm sorry that comes across really bad i
hope england win yeah obviously okay
let's
yeah okay um listen let's go to the
express
now i'm looking out the window um
it's pouring with rain but there's a
heat wave on the on the way the express
is saying thomas
yeah as always the express is reporting
that there's a heat wave on the way as
indeed there is always the coldest
summer on record there is going to be
the hottest summer on record
apparently they say that the weather
maps to suggest that a spanish plume
is on the way whatever that means 28
degrees basking in sunshine
i mean if we're serious for half a
second i suppose it's good news from the
sense of people have been cooped up for
many months now it'd be good to get
outside enjoy some sunshine
also you know it's nice to be outside
sitting outside in hospitality these i
i've loved some of the
the new expanded outdoor seating areas
that we've got in hospitality
i hope they stay with us i fear as as
british weather sets in
it come the ottoman winter they won't
but good news from that perspective i'm
sure
sun sounds good for everyone we'll keep
our fingers crossed for for a balmy
summer
oh yes 28 degrees c they say right yeah
something like that i think 83
fahrenheit whatever that means i think
28 degrees celsius
is too hot for me too hot for you okay
well you can be inside not watching the
football
absolutely an ideal combination an ideal
combination
okay afia and thomas thanks a lot we'll
see you next hour
um lots more still to come here on
breakfast obviously
lots more about that match we'll be back
in a moment
[Music]